less company it's great to be back in
Harlem I think parlons an amazing place
over there do I love doing shows here in
Harlem I'll tell you why it is change it
is changing all the time Harlem it has
changed so much in the past year you
know things are different when you hear
the phrase meet me at the Whole Foods on
Malcolm X Boulevard I didn't know that
was a thing but today obviously New York
holds a very special place in my heart I
had a show here for many years in New
York first rate of you might yeah you
might you might remember it it was
called The Vagina Monologues
people like it when I get sad at the end
of my yeah yeah I don't know why they
just really like that part one yeah the
guy that gets really sad yeah tell it
there's a lot going on in the city right
now big mayoral election for New York
City tomorrow I know you're excited
about that I can feel the energy oh it's
a tight race I tell ya this is crazy
Mayor Bill DeBlasio has a 33 point lead
yeah yeah after hearing this the New
York Giants said what's a lead
[Applause]
yeah okay that was pretty good yeah all
right that better than the vagina one
yeah
another thing that's changed a lot
changing here all the time is the subway
I took the D train today it has Wi-Fi
that blew my mind it didn't used to be
like that the trains have Wi-Fi now the
guy sitting across from me was able to
text me his dick pick
it saves so much time there's no zipper
there's no trench coat and in it it's
like you and he have a secret yeah yeah
yeah instead of the whole car exactly
yeah sure you know I love about you know
what I love about this town yeah
I love that Sun isn't it set up with
that joke I said you know they have
Wi-Fi in the subways and a person over
here went not all of them that was you
stand up give her a hand she's
thank you
nice to meet you I love Bonin Facebook
that's the head of the MTA that's how
she got those yeah exactly
everybody here has a complaint no all of
them I don't care that it's alive though
I don't care there is other news this
morning did you hear this this morning a
woman was fired from her job because she
was photographed flipping off President
Trump yeah yeah two story that's a true
story
yeah when asked for comment Melania
Trump said I didn't like being first
lady anyway
I'm channeling Melania I understand good
of a woman yeah Stan
you